warnings have been put in place our
correspondent caterina vittotsi reports
from one of the areas at risk
it's the last thing anyone needs
storm kristoff is sweeping across the
north of england
affecting homes businesses belongings
and covid means help is taking longer to
arrive
everything has to happen in a socially
distanced way so
it's it's more difficult to go into
people's houses that can still be done
when necessary
when it's a priority it will be done in
a covered safe way
but obviously that has an impact on what
you can do and how quickly you can do it
the full impact of this storm will be
felt overnight but we've already seen
how dangerous it can be
rescue teams in county durham saved this
man from a freezing
flooded river on tuesday evening he
tried to cross it
in his supermarket delivery van
the real concern now is what happens
here this is the river mersey in south
manchester it's at some of its highest
ever levels and it's rising as we speak
and the bad news for people that live
around here is that this rain is
forecast to just continue
3 000 homes here are at risk of flooding
including dorians who's 85.
you don't sleep because you keep
thinking oh am i going to have to get up
and
you know it does get you down a bit and
you have to keep watching
to see if it's coming in are you worried
about how bad it might be this time
whilst we're talking a neighbour pops by
to tell dory in the nearby river is
rising fast and she might be evacuated
tonight it seems that they might
break the bank might break more will
come
so is that right i had not moved
anything
i have now though and it is coming
somebody's coming
to take us away evacuations have already
started
police say lives are at risk
whilst flood teams try and protect power
lines
and relieve pressure from the main river
many people don't
really understand the risk from flood
water it can come really quickly
the damage it can cause to properties
can go on for months and months
afterwards if not years
and the fear that people have had
afterwards you know my heart goes out to
those communities i've walked in those
houses i've seen those people that have
been flooding
so now is the time to act waters here
will peak overnight but rain is expected
to keep falling for another 24 hours
bringing with it uncertainty and danger
caterina for totsi sky news in
manchester